hey youtubers is Charlie hopefully you
guys have all had a chance to see
guardians of the galaxy by now
it is definitely one of if not the most
fun Marvel movie so far they've even
already confirmed the sequel for July
2017 so this video is gonna be my top 5
picks for storage they should adapt this
is just meant to get things started once
they announced new castings we can get a
better picture for what the new movies
gonna look like if you're just finding
me for the first time I do Marvel videos
every week be sure to subscribe to get
everything
and yes I am totally gonna do videos for
all the Marvel TV shows whenever they
get here - here's something funny to
think about this past weekend Guardians
made about a hundred and sixty five
million dollars worldwide so if you're a
James Gunn you'd probably celebrate by
taking a vacation right well he actually
spent the weekend working on guardians -
and he didn't just do that he actually
ate a lot of candy and talks a lot with
fans on Twitter that told it sounds like
something I would do after finishing a
really big video just start working on
the next one and tweet pictures of
dancing baby Groot
there were so many Easter eggs during
the movie that I feel like half of my
list is a no-brainer so here's my top
five stories I think they should do for
guardians - careful for spoilers from
the movie if you haven't seen it yet but
all wait just a second okay everybody
ready here we go number five the
universal Church of Truth tries to
cleanse the galaxy of impurity and bring
back the mages the evil future version
of Adam warlock warlock is a huge
character in the Marvel Universe all by
himself so he shows up in various ways
on this list but just think of it as
like the church's crusade to bring him
back it was like Ronan being the main
villain at guardians of the galaxy
anthea knows being on the periphery
the thing about sequels is is that from
a narrative standpoint there are only a
couple directions they could go in they
can go bigger and up the stakes they can
go smaller and go deeper into specific
characters or it can be a time travel
story which is also kind of like an
alternate universe story depending on
how the outcome is altered let's talk
more about time travel in the Marvel
Universe in a sec but using the church
would be a big escalation in the comics
the church serves mages which is an evil
version of Adam warlock at a certain
point warlock absorbed himself into the
soul gem the Infinity gem that is to
prevent that future major self from
coming about so it's possible that the
church could go on a quest for the soul
gem to try and bring the mages back
there's a couple of things I think that
would make that very difficult and
reasons why it probably wouldn't happen
mostly that Adam warlock was an easter
egg in the post-credits scene from Thor
the dark world
that cocoon in the background that's
Adam warlocks cocoon and guardians in
the post-credits scene the collectors
cases are all shattered you know because
of that big explosion the cocoon from
dark world is broken meeting whatever
was inside escaped obviously talking
about Adam warlock the tease is just
that Adam warlock is out in the Marvel
Universe free to be used in any movie
potentially there was actually a point
of Marvel Comics history when they put a
company-wide ban on using that character
without giving a whole lot of reason
sometimes characters will be retired for
a little while they don't think that
they'd fit into the editorial for what
they're trying to do with the comics but
moving on to a little bit more time
travel number four the corvax saga this
is a time travel story but they can
alter it just a little bit I don't think
that the future Guardian sequel will
feature another gem I think we'll see
that gauntlet maybe at the end of the
next Thor movie but we have no idea
where the time gem is either it'll show
up in Avengers age of Ultron or some
other characters movie in Phase three
but the first movie to deal with time
travel will involve the time gem so in
the corvex saga in the comics this being
comes back in time absorbs all of
Galactus is collected knowledge becomes
this super being tries to remake the
earth into a utopia his name was michael
korvac
eventually the Avengers in the Guardians
team up to stop him and it's one of
those predestination paradox stories
whereby at the end he sends his
consciousness back to the future that he
originally came from setting off the
chain of events that caused him to
travel back in the first place so it's
like this never-ending causality loop
that seems way too complicated already
for them to do in a Marvel movie
typically those types of stories the
ones that they end up doing on-screen
tend to be very linear and very easy to
follow so think of maybe core vac
getting ultimate knowledge in the
guardians having to team up with a few
new characters and Benicio Del Toro's
character to take him down they kind of
did this in the first movie but in the
core vac saga del Toro's character the
collector sends his daughter to help the
guardians I'm moving that the collector
becomes a much bigger part of the story
in the sequel regardless of what it ends
up being but upping the stakes a billion
times
number three Marvel's the end a group of
celestial beings learn to harness this
power called the heart of the universe
it's a Higgs boson situation whereby the
entire universe is defined in terms of
this specific power things go a little
sideways and in order to stop them
Thanos absorbs it into himself becoming
one with the universe
in the course of saving everyone Thanos
learns that the universe is ultimately
doomed to die and the only way to save
it is to destroy it and reboot it he
gets pissed but the aspect of death and
Adam warlock convinced him to do the
right thing
he reboots the universe but in the
process erases himself from existence I
know the Infinity Gauntlet storyline is
all about Thanos gaining ultimate power
but it's a little bit different when
he's wearing the gauntlet with the gems
in it he just becomes more powerful when
he absorbs the heart of the universe he
essentially becomes one with everything
all the cosmic beings of the universe
like eternity infinity death Galactus
they all just become part of him so like
I said before if that seems way too
complicated for them to do in a movie
but take the idea of fan o's learning
about a fundamental flaw in the universe
wanting to save it by destroying it and
make that part of his backstory like his
quest for the gems just becomes part of
an ongoing quest for him to fix
everything by destroying it and
rebooting it saving the universe by
blowing it up that actually kind of
sounds like a Doctor Who story which is
probably why they won't end up doing it
moving on to something a little bit more
practical though number two the
formation of the coal obsidian or the
midnight slaughter this is a group of
lieutenants that Thanos assembles in the
recent infinity storyline from last year
it's Corvus glaive Proxima midnight
supergiant black dwarf and ebony maw
internally they call themselves the
Black Order and each member is called a
dread Lord so right now in the movies
Thanos only has a couple people around
him that we met there's the other who's
actually played by Aleksey Denisof which
is actually cool fun Whedon verse fact
but because Gamora and nebula was split
on him he needs more lieutenants it
would be pretty cool to see Fanus
assemble his own evil Avengers I don't
know that a single movie could handle
that many characters considering you
already have five guardian characters
returning but Danis will eventually have
to replace those missing team members of
his and the number one story that I want
to see them do in The Guardian sequel
Thanos his backstory combined with a lot
of different other elements of major
comic-book arcs usually what ends up
happening in Marvel movies is they take
pieces of different stories and use them
together so I'd really like to see a
deep cut on Thanos that spells out his
past whenever we do get to Avengers 3 we
don't have to spend half that movie
explaining why he's assembling the gems
so here's a couple stories that they
could layer into that there's war of
kings - the Shiar because Fox has rights
to them
add in Adam warlock as in like an anti
Thanos storyline that dovetails into the
next Avengers movie so you see the rise
of these two celestial beings in the
Guardians getting caught in between them
in the middle of this giant galactic
race war now it's actually starting to
sound like Game of Thrones in space
which is another reason why they might
just kind of water it down and make a
lot simpler so don't plan on Game of
Thrones even though that sounds really
awesome and don't plan on seeing another
infinity gem the price say that for
another Marvel movie it's pretty obvious
though that they will do more Thanos and
Peter Quill's father after that all bets
are off
whenever Glenn Close said that quill
came from something ancient she was
talking about an ancient race his father
in the comics is JSON of spartax Emperor
this Bardo their cousin race to the
Shiar like I said the Shiar are Fox so
it's possible that they could change his
backstory just because of legal issues
until we get confirmation though let's
just assume it's gonna be the same as it
is in the comics it's likely that quill
will have to get his father's help to
fight Bannos eventually like use this
Bartoli fleet the way they use the Nova
Corps to help out in the first movie
that whole scene where Glenn Close was
explaining Peter Quill's genetics to him
was a little bit weird I mean this part
I aren't a secret race and if the Nova
Corps knows what an infinity gem is then
why can't their super machine identify
Sparta why DNA I don't want to poke too
many holes in it but it did bug me a
little bit they might change it and make
Peter Quill's father a celestial being
like vanos Thanos technically is not a
celestial but he descends from a
celestial race the Titans so for all
intents and purposes he's a super being
fun fact in the comics Peter Quill's
grandfather is named Isan as an ISA on
the searcher who's in the movie no big
celestial being they're different
characters Isan his grandfather is a
different character from Isan the
searcher but they could use that fact to
connect Peter quill to the Celestials in
the sequel but now it's your turn let me
know in the comments which story do you
want to see them do for the sequel from
the comics and do you think that Peter
Quill's father is going to be a
celestial or if they'll do it just like
it is in the comics my next Marvel video
is probably gonna be for Avengers 2 so
be sure to subscribe to get it
now the Guardians is starting to slowly
go away we can start to focus on age of
Ultron so if you haven't seen the movie
yet please go see it it is so amazing or
see again I'm actually planning on
seeing again too right now click here to
get my review if you haven't seen it yet
and click here to get my breakdown of
the age of Ultron trailer for Comic Con
the Avengers 2 trailer thank you so much
for watching I'll see you guys tomorrow
high five
you